le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 est donc passé
vous l'avez peut-être suivi d'ailleurs
avec moi en direct sur ma chaîne switch
puisque vous étiez des centaines de
milliers en cumulé quoi qu'il en soit
dans cette vidéo j'ai donc vous résumer
ce qu'il faut retenir de ce premier tour
que ce soit les scores les réactions ou
encore le vote des jeunes lors de cette
élection a laissé une vidéo je le
précise qu'on tourne très tardivement je
m'excuse d'avancé pour la fatigue qui
peut peut-être se ressentir forcément
dans le fond c'est donc emmanuel macron
et marine le pen qui sont qualifiés pour
le second tour selon les chiffres
officiels et définitifs du ministère de
l'intérieur pour les autres candidats
les résultats définitifs s'affiche
actuellement à l'écran ce qu'on voit
c'est donc un trio tête suivis ensuite
des autres qui sont bien plus bas à
commencer par eric zemmour et puis vous
le voyez vallée pécresse yannick jadot
ou encore jean lassalle je vous laisse
faire pause pour prendre le temps de
voir ses résultats définitifs si jamais
vous le souhaitez alors dans la soirée
jean luc mélenchon et son camp ont eu
l'espoir d'une potentielle remonta
d'armes d'une potentielle donc remonter
jusqu'à dépasser marine le pen une
estimation de l'institut de sondages
ipsos a notamment beaucoup fait parler
puisque les besoins à 22h30 l'institut
ipsos et bien déclaré qu'il y avait
seulement 0,8 point d'écart entre marine
le pen et jean luc mélenchon les
chiffres des instituts de sondages donc
par exemple il faut qu ipsos ou encore
et lab donne en fait une estimation des
résultats grâce à un échantillon de
bureaux de vote ce témoin et grâce à un
algorithme pour les grandes villes il
faut comprendre que les chiffres des
instituts de sondages l'ont que par
exemple il faut à pipe sauce pour encore
et lab ce sont des chiffres qui viennent
donc à partir de 20h et qui donne en
fait une estimation des résultats grâce
à un échantillon de bureaux de vote
témoins et grâce à un algorithme pour
les grandes villes bref dans la soirée
c'était car de 0 8% a suscité une vague
d'espoir pour la gauche met donc au fur
et à mesure de la soirée eh bien les
résultats officiels du ministère de
l'intérieur sont tombés et certes et
bien au fil de la soirée
l'écart entre marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon s'est resserré à mesure
notamment que les grandes villes ont été
d oui y ait des grandes villes qui voter
davantage pour jean luc mélenchon que
marine le pen mais pour autant donc vous
l'aurez compris avec les résultats
finaux du ministère de l'intérieur ce
sont bien emmanuel macron et marine le
pen qui sont qualifiés pour le second
tour ça c'est donc pour les résultats
maintenant voyons notamment pour les
autres informations à jour à retenir à
commencer par les réactions des
différents candidats l'actuel président
la république et candidat m une macron à
d'abord remercié ceux qui lui avaient
fait confiance dès le premier tour et
puis il a aussi salué les 11 autres
candidats dans l'ordre alphabétique des
candidats qui l'a fait applaudir par la
foule qui était présente face à lui et
ensuite notamment invité les citoyens à
faire barrage à l'extrême droite il a
ajouté que rien n'était joué pour le
moment pour le second tour il a terminé
notamment avec cette tirade je veux vous
dire ce soir que je mettrai toutes mes
forces pour convaincre chacun que le
seul projet pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet crédible contre la
vie chère c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet des travailleurs de
tous ceux qui sont au bord du chemin
c'est le nôtre
que le seul projet de la france c'est de
l'europe c'est le nôtre
je crois en lui on nous tous quels que
soient nos parcours nos milieux nous
tous
quels que soient nos origines nos
territoires nous tous quels que soient
nos opinions et nos croyances nous tous
c'est cela la france
10 28
nous on voter marine le pen a appelé je
cite les français de droite gauche est
d'ailleurs de toutes origines à
rejoindre son rassemblement
elle a tenu à s'adresser je cite à tous
ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour emmanuel
macron assurant qu'elle serait je cite
là aussi selon elle la présidente de
tous les français le peuple français
s'est exprimé et me fait l'honneur
d'être qualifiés au second tour face au
président sortant
[Applaudissements]
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas voté
pour emmanuel macron ont bien sûr
vocation à rejoindre ce rassemblement
ensemble nous allons construire avec
enthousiasme et conviction
cette victoire pour mettre en oeuvre
ses besoins
aujourd'hui avec bonheur
grands pays dans le troisième millénaire
alors évidemment les deux candidats
qualifiés ne sont pas les seuls à s'être
exprimés tous les candidats en fait ont
pris la parole tour à tour pendant la
soirée et certains ont donné des
consignes de vote il ya en fait deux
candidats qui ont très clairement appelé
à voter pour emmanuel macron pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite est à marine
le pen il s'agit de la candidate du
parti socialiste anne hidalgo ainsi que
du candidat écologiste eelv yannick
jadot au passage concernant yannick
jadot et bien son parti récolte moins de
5% des suffrages ce qui veut dire donc
que les frais de campagne de yannick
jadot et bien ne sont pas remboursés et
donc le candidat écologiste a lancé dès
ce soir un appel aux dons puisque seuls
les candidats ayant plus de 5% des
suffrages et bien se voir rembourser
leurs frais de campagne valérie pécresse
la candidate de droite du parti
républicain a reconnu je cite une
déception personnelle et collective il a
tenu aussi à souligner le combat des
législatives qui s'annoncent puisque au
mois de juin et laura les élections
législatives qui certes à élire les
députés de l'assemblée nationale alors
comme je vous l'avais annoncé cette
semaine elle n'a pas appeler ses
électeurs à voter pour emmanuel macron
mais elle a déclaré qu elle voterait
elle personnellement pour le candidat de
la république en marche et actuel
président de la république de son côté
le candidat de reconquête eric zemmour
s'est félicité de sa campagne
présidentielle débuté en octobre dernier
estimant je cite que son parti avait
fait en trois mois ce qu'aucun
politicien n'avait fait en trois ans il
a ensuite appelé sans grande surprise à
voter pour marine le pen on notera par
ailleurs que nicolas dupont aignan donc
le candidat de debout la france a lui
aussi appelé à voter pour marine le pen
face à emmanuel macron pour le second
tour pour d'information nicolas dupont
aignan en 2017 s'étaient ralliés déjà à
marine le pen après le premier tour et
donc c'est sans grande surprise là aussi
qu'il rejoint marine le pen ça c'est
donc pour ceux qui ont officiellement
donné une consigne de vote pour le
second tour qui ont clairement donc si
tu es un des deux candidats mais
d'autres candidats majoritairement à
gauche ont tout de même pris la parole
et ont appelé à ne pas voter pour marine
le pen c'est le cas notamment de jean
luc mélenchon qui n'a pas cité le nom
des menus et le maquereau mais qui a
répété à plusieurs reprises qu'il ne
fallait pas donner de voix à marine le
pen et je ne ferai pas de nature à le
voir madame le pen
il ne faut pas donné une seule voix à
madame lopez
il ne faut pas donner une seule voix à
madame le pen
[Applaudissements]
voilà je crois que jamais sage prochaine
partie a été entendue même chose par
ailleurs pour philippe poutou qui a
appelé à ne pas voter pour marine le pen
tout en dénonçant une nouvelle fois la
politique d' emmanuel macron qu'il
estime n'être je cite en rien un rempart
contre l'extrême droite de son côté le
candidat communiste fabien roussel a
appelé je cite à battre l'extrême droite
à la mettre en échec en se servant du
seul bulletin qui sera à sa disposition
mais sans citer donc expressément
l'actuel président de la république et
enfin jean lassalle et nathalie arthaud
n'ont pas donné de consigne de vote pour
le second tour et dans le cas plus
précisément de nathalie arthaud la
candidate d'extrême gauche a dénoncé les
candidats qui sont selon elle je cite
des ennemis mortels pour les
travailleurs voilà donc pour ce qui est
des réactions et les consignes de vote
pour le second tour je le sais vous
parler maintenant d'un sondage en
sondage qui a été réalisé par elad pour
bfm tv notamment sur le vote des jeunes
un sondage donc qui me semblent
forcément intéressant a évoqué à
analyser même si évidemment tout ça sera
précisée avec les différents sondages et
détails dans les prochains jours mais
chez les 18 24 ans c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui arrive en tête avec 34%
des voix donc de vraies mines macron qui
récolte lui 25% des voix de ces mêmes 18
24 ans et chez les 25-34 ans donc la
tranche d'âge au dessus jean luc
mélenchon arrive là aussi assez
largement en tête des suffrages avec 31%
marine le pen arrive ensuite seconde
avec 27% ça c'est donc les chiffres pour
les jeunes gros score donc pour jean luc
mélenchon suivi des venues de macron en
tout cas pour ce qui est des 18 24 ans
al'inverse si on prend les 65 ans et
plus et bien c'est emmanuel macron qui
arrive en tête avec 41% des voix contre
seulement 17% pour marine le pen quant à
marine le pen en fait elle est favorite
chez les tranches d'âge intermédiaire
disons entre les 35 64 ans avec 29% des
voix toujours selon l'institut et là ben
voilà donc pour tout ça je vous laisse
je veux dire un mot sur le taux
d'abstention a très rapidement donc le
pourcentage de personnes inscrites sur
les listes électorales mais qui ne sont
pas allés voter
et bien cette année ce taux d'abstention
était de 27 3% pour le premier tour
contre 22 2 % en 2017 selon les chiffres
diffusés sial pour tf1 et lci qui seront
à préciser dans les prochaines heures et
donc moins de gens qui sont allés voter
lors de cette élection par rapport au
premier tour de 2017 mais cela dit le
score d'abstention de 2002 n'a pas été
battu parce qu'à l'époque le taux
d'abstention était encore plus important
28 4% des électeurs n'étaient pas allés
voter ce qu'on va donc ces trois
candidats à plus de 20% ému de macron
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon
largement devant les autres candidats
c'est sûrement d'ailleurs le signe d'une
recomposition du paysage politique
autour de trois blocs est là où
jusqu'ici pendant des années et jusqu'en
2017 on avait plutôt deux parties un de
gauche et de droite avec le ps et les
républicains aujourd'hui vous l'aurez
compris c'est absolument pas le cas et
pour vous donner des chiffres en 2012
donc à 10 ans tout juste le ps et l'ump
donc l'ancêtre des républicains faisait
environ 54% des voix au premier tour or
ce soir eh bien c'est pas 54 % en cumul
et que ces deux partis font mais ils
font à peine 7% répondent on a donc un
nouveau duel pour le second tour entre m
et le maquereau et marine le pen les
différents sondages a publié ce soir
place les deux candidats réellement au
coude à coude dans ce second tour avec
par exemple un sondage ifop fiducial
réalisé ce soir qui crédite emmanuel
macron à 51% des voix et marine le pen à
49 cela dit donc vous l'aurez compris
absolument rien n'est joué un sondage
dont je le répète à chaque vidéo mais je
leur dis quand même c'est une
cartographie de l'opinion à un instant t
on l'a vu aussi ce soir il ya eu quand
même d un certain nombre d car on aura
le temps d'analyser en détail tout ça
les écarts entre les sondages et ce qui
s'est passé ce soir mais aussi un
certain nombre de surprises ce soir on
verra donc ce qu'il en est et il y aura
deux semaines jusqu'au second tour le 24
avril pour voir comment est ce que tout
cela évolue paraître a priori donc ces
femmes nées l'écart sera beaucoup plus
serré par rapport à 2010 est pour rappel
en 2010 est l'écart était plus important
que ce qu'on voit là dans les derniers
sondages puisque ses 66% des français
qui avaient voté pour emmanuel macron
contre 34% pour marine le pen voilà donc
pour le débrief de cette première soirée
littoral ça me semblait assez essentiel
malgré la fatigue que vous ressentez
très probablement de faire cette vidéo
pour vous résumer quand même tout ce qui
s'est passé ce soir évidemment dans les
prochains jours on va prendre le temps
d'analyser tout ça parce que y aura
beaucoup de choses à analyser et on
prendra le temps de le faire et dans les
prochaines heures on donnera des
informations que ce soit sur youtube
dans les actes du jour je vous mets le
lien de la chaîne youtube directement en
descriptions la chaîne youtube on mai
donc les actus du jour chaque jour mais
aussi notamment sur instagram n'hésitez
pas à le nom du compte c'est eux les
crips pour l'écouter je crois que je dis
merci encore d'avoir été aussi nombreux
à suivre cette soirée électorale ce soir
en direct avec moi sur twitter on fera
la même chose du coup forcément pour le
second tour connaissances vous prenez
vos proches et on se dit du coup a très
vite
[Musique]